good morning Hank it's Tuesday I want to
talk today about the refugee crisis
going on around the world but let's
begin with an old saying often
attributed to that great expert in the
field of human evil Joseph Stalin when
one man dies that's a tragedy when
thousands die that's a statistic large
numbers can feel cold and distant and
even kind of comforting because they
don't feel like people and I think
that's one of the reasons much of the
world was able to ignore the years old
Syrian refugee crisis until recently but
then after thousands of refugees died
this year trying to get to Europe one
three year old boy's body washed ashore
in Turkey
his name was Aylan Kurdi and he drowned
with his five-year-old brother and his
mom trying to get to greece his father
Abdullah survived and has now returned
to Syria to bury his wife and children
in fact would offer the opportunity to
resettle in another country Abdullah
said now I don't want anything what was
precious is gone to talk about the
refugee crisis we need statistics but
let us not forget what is precious so
for the past four and a half years there
has been a horrific civil war in Syria
which began with the hope of the 2011
Arab Spring protests several
dictatorships were toppled during the
Arab Spring although some have since
ended up with new dictators but in Syria
long reigning dictator Bashar al-assad
has refused to relinquish power and
instead has battled the rebellion with
astonishing violence including torturing
children and gassing his own people with
chemical weapons so back in 2011 Syria
had a population of 22 point four
million people here's what it looks like
today more than 250,000 people have been
killed about ten point six million
Syrians less than half the population
still within their homes seven point six
million people have been forced to flee
within Syria either moving to refugee
camps or to areas that are for the
moment safer and another 4 million
Syrians have left the country entirely
although people about 1.6 million
currently live in Turkey there are about
a million each and Lebanon and Jordan
and there are a few hundred thousand
more in Iraq and Egypt 95 percent of
Syrian refugees live in those countries
and they have been stretched incredibly
thin by this refugee crisis Jordan's
population is now 25% refugees you've
probably seen the huge sprawling camps
in Jordan and Lebanon for Refugees and
everything is completely underfunded
because the UN's refugee agency doesn't
have
nearly enough money to deal with this
number of refugees and in Turkey most
refugees live in a kind of legal limbo
outside of camps because turkey doesn't
expel them but they also aren't allowed
to work so even though many Syrians have
good education and labor skills they
can't make a living and so in search of
lasting refuge thousands have turned to
Europe and they pay smugglers thousands
of euros to get them by a boat from
Turkey Morocco or Egypt to Malta
southern Italy or Greece's southern
islands those smugglers are essentially
the only people benefiting from Europe's
inconsistent inhumane and disorganized
response to the refugee crisis to quote
the UN's High Commissioner on refugees
more effective international cooperation
is required to crack down on smugglers
including those operating inside the EU
but in ways that allow for the victims
to be protected but none of these
efforts will be effective without
opening up more opportunities for people
to come legally to Europe and find
safety upon arrival and that leads us to
a very important distinction between the
words migrant and refugee this has often
been called a migrant crisis but it
really isn't because migrants choose to
leave their homes in search of better
education or employment opportunities
refugees to again quote the UNHCR are
persons fleeing armed conflict or
persecution these are people for whom
the denial of asylum has potentially
deadly consequences and ever since the
1951 Refugee Commission refugees have
had certain rights under international
law these include the right not to be
returned to their country of origin if
their safety cannot be assured the right
not to be penalized for entering a
country illegally if they request asylum
and the rights to life security
religious expression primary education
free access to courts and equal
treatment by taxing authorities if a
migrant arrives illegally in the
European Union they can be turned around
and in most countries sent home fairly
quickly but a refugee and most of the
people arriving in Europe right now are
refugees they have certain rights under
international law that all of Europe and
basically all of the world has agreed to
for the last 65 years ensure European
countries have no obligations to
refugees until those refugees arrive in
Europe but once a refugee is in your
country you have certain legal
responsibilities to them and that's why
the boat smuggling has continued
European governments want to make it
difficult for refugees to get to Europe
they benefit when the trip is danger
if it were made safe or easy there would
be far more refugees coming to Europe
the real solution to dramatically
increase the number of refugees legally
accepted through non smuggling routes
like a quota system
well that stuff's politically unpopular
but until legal opportunities are
available the smuggling and deaths will
continue to again quote the UNHCR
thousands of refugee parents are risking
the lives of their children on unsafe
smuggling boats primarily because they
have no choice and this is true not only
for Syrians because only about half the
people seeking asylum through these sea
routes are from Syria
another 12% are from Afghanistan which
was the world's leading producer of
refugees for 30 years until Syria came
along another 8% are from the Northeast
African nation of Eritrea which has one
of the worst Human Rights records on
earth it's government has been cited by
the UN for executions torture forced
labor and systemic rape by government
officials so about 70 percent of the
people trying to get to Europe are from
those three countries of course there
are also many migrants trying to get to
Europe via these dangerous overwater
routes so most of the people were
hearing about on the news are refugees
and the distinction is incredibly
important okay so we have this massive
humanitarian crisis who's to blame
pretty much everybody I mean the Assad
regime definitely gets a lot of the
blame but so do Iran and Russia and
China who are providing direct or
indirect support to that regime and
doing very little about the resulting
refugee crisis the Arab states of the
Gulf although they've pledged financial
support to Syrian refugees have accepted
zero-zero refugees from Syria
Australia's refugee record is truly
abysmal and possibly in violation of
international law
Canada is accepting 30% fewer refugees
than they were a decade ago and the
United States is to blame as well we've
accepted a tiny number of Syrian
refugees fewer for instance than Brazil
and instead of talking seriously about
how to address the refugee crisis our
immigration debate has become
increasingly racist and irrational for
instance you often hear in the US and
Europe that immigrants are
disproportionately likely to commit
crimes but that's simply untrue a huge
body of data says that refugees and
first-generation immigrants to the
United States commit crimes at a much
lower rate than other Americans okay and
then there's
the truth is the xenophobic responses to
the refugee crisis scene from some
European governments are just shameful
like when Hungary's prime minister says
that they must keep Muslims out of
Europe to quote keep Europe Christian
he's not just denying the multicultural
and multi-religious history of Europe
he's denying the international law that
requires countries to protect and house
refugees regardless of their religious
beliefs Hank when discussing refugees I
often hear well it's not our problem or
we have to take care of our people but
we are one species sharing one
profoundly interconnected world and
humans all humans are our people and
when the oppressed and marginalized die
because they are oppressed and
marginalized the powerful are at fault
three-year-old Aylan Kurdi would be
alive today if his family had been
welcomed by the European Union or by
Canada or Australia or the United States
or Brazil or the list goes on and on and
I think the reason the world reacted so
viscerally to that image of that dead
boy on the beach is that instinctively
we all knew that his blood was on all of
our hands we have legal obligations to
refugees under international law but we
also have ethical obligations to them
because they are our people in fact one
of the reasons we're in this mess to
begin with is that for too long we've
labored under the delusion that regional
crises have no global importance
imagining any widespread human problem
as belonging to someone else is
catastrophic Lee misguided like an Ebola
outbreak in Liberia is just a Liberian
problem right well sure until it's a
Nigerian problem and a German problem
and an American problem and as we've
learned all too painfully the Syrian
civil war is not only a Syrian problem I
mean for one thing it's led to the
growth of Isis a terrorist organization
that kills not only Syrians and Iraqis
but Ethiopians and Americans and
Brazilians and Koreans and Turks in
recent weeks people in Europe at train
stations and that football games have
been promising that refugees are welcome
it's a moving sight and an encouraging
one and I hope that European governments
respond in kind but the hardest work is
not in making the promise it's in
keeping it and this is going to be a
long-term expensive and complex
challenge for the world
and as the UNHCR has said this massive
flow of people will not stop until the
root causes of their plight are
addressed the ultimate solution the only
old
solution was outlined clearly for us by
a 13 year old Syrian refugee my message
please help the scene seeing no you you
just said the word and you don't know
you don't want to go to Europe just stop
the war decision until then hey until
this war stops we have a legal and moral
obligation to provide safe harbor for
this young man and others like him and
we also must provide financial support
to the less developed countries from
Jordan to Pakistan to Iraq that are
shouldering 90% of the world's refugee
burden Hank I've included links below to
donate to the UN's refugee work as well
as Save the Children's refugee work I
will see you on Friday